[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows that a picture is
worth a thousand words the drawings show
them what really happened and what did
you draw a yellow rabbit hitting the
Subscribe button I can see you now well
great that is the point of the Subscribe
button after all thanks Abby finally
finally it's happened after eight
agonizingly long years in development
hell hopping from Studio to Studio
director to director the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie is finally out for you to
go see right now and man has this been a
commercial hit as of the writing of this
script just one weekend into release the
movie's made over $152 million at the
box office more than seven times its own
budget and that's despite being
available to stream on peacock where oh
wait it's also the most viewed movie on
peacock ever suck on that My Big Fat
Greek Wedding 3 it's also Blum House's
most successful opening weekend to date
which means that more people are turning
out to see spring trap wielding his
knife than Michael Myers maybe now
Hollywood will finally bother to get the
name of this thing right and his other
movie Friday Nights at Freddy's comes to
theaters and streaming on peacock
October 27th Five Nights at Freddy's
what did I say Friday nights it's been
eight or nine years since I first met
Scott cauthorne who created this why do
we get it wrong or not who cares forget
them this thing was made for the fans
from Sparky the dog to dream theory to
it's just a theory you bet it is and
today we're getting back to those
theorist roots today we're theorizing
about the actual movie and boy is there
a lot to talk about here true story
after the movie I basically locked
myself in the room with Lee and Tom the
film and Game Theory creative directors
and we busted out our trusty whiteboard
to figure out exactly what was going on
in the movie and where the story was
going to head in the future cuz there
were just a lot of details left hanging
what was up with the balloon boy
figurine how's no one freaked out by the
fact that there are bodies in those
animatronics wasn't this like the most
structurally unsound table for it of all
time that last one perhaps the biggest
mystery of them all today we're going to
be looking at all the Easter eggs
secrets and hidden lore from the movie
than comparing those to other parts of
the franchise both the books and the
games in order to predict where the
story of the the FNAF 2 movie is going
to go years before they actually make it
so that's our one job for today but
before we get to it I also have to shout
out our brand new line of officially
licensed FNAF Theory Weare that's two
jobs yeah I guess you're right Vanessa
it is two jobs anyway let me tell you
guys these are some of the most fun
unique items that we've ever done and
not only are the designs fun let's be
honest there's also a lot of just FNAF
stuff out there in the market which is
also why we wanted to create the highest
quality clothing out there complete with
rubber patches embroidered detailing
soft teddy fleece this stuff isn't just
FNAF merch it is FNAF apparel oh in case
you are wondering every item in this
collection had to be approved by Mr
Scott cawthorne himself look we're so
tight I even know how to pronounce his
name right and in this collection we've
got something for everyone do you like
graphic te's check out the Retro band
T-shirts featuring Freddy purple guy and
of course music man you want something a
little bit more subtle the all over
prints of the confetti tea and the
employee tea will make you look good
without screaming I'm a FNAF fan in
everyone's face if you're in the mood to
do some cute FNAF founding the Chica
cheer bundles got you covered with a
chica themed top top skirt with unders
scir and high socks and of course we've
got jackets oh boy we've got jackets
it's not a theory wear collection unless
there are some killer jackets in here
and we had fun with this batch you have
the FNAF High varsity jacket inspired by
chica's anime adventures and ultimate
custom night with colorful patches of
all your favorite characters down the
faux leather sleeves and a class a 1983
embroidered patch on the back for
obvious reasons there is only one thing
that could possibly go wrong yeah and
that's falling in love with another
jacket like our withered fleece complete
with 3D animatronic endoskeleton
detailing that's a endo2 to be specific
so make sure you put that one on your
next timeline and while the outside is
nice and soft and fluffy the inside is
waterproof and purple in case you feel
like flipping the entire thing inside
out and sporting the franchise's most
notorious color and lastly probably the
most fun piece we've ever done the Monty
jacket it is faux alligator leather
that's glammed out to the max with
bright yellow interior and sharp metal
studs to show that you're the radest
reptile on the Block any guitar playing
bunnies better watch their backs when
you're wearing this one if any of this
has caught your eye and you want to show
off both your love of FNAF and
theorizing go check out our official
FNAF collection over at Theory wear.com
that's t h e o r y w a r.com and now
with that Shameless self-promotion out
of the way let's just hop into the
theory shall we so to begin we should
point out that we already do have some
vague idea where the sequel's going to
head in an interview with variety FNAF
director Emma Tammy explained that the
first movie was tied to the first game
so a second film would likely tie into a
second game which duh kind of goes
without saying but also should probably
make our lives easy right n not quite as
we mentioned in our first prediction
Theory the strategy for the movie verse
seems to be taking iconic bits and
pieces from across the entire franchise
Games books fan theories even hoaxes and
Distilling it all down into the most
recognizable version of FNAF there is
that's how we got Mike Schmidt from FNAF
1 hanging out with Vanessa from security
breach fighting springtrap from FNAF 3
and saving Abby from getting stuck into
a spring lock version of Ella from the
silverized novel with an ending that was
ripped straight out of the fourth closet
it is literally FNAF the smoothie
everything dumped into a blender chopped
up and then poured back out onto the big
screen so yeah while it did follow the
same broad Strokes as the first game
five nights in the fnaf1 pizzeria with
ghost kids and Suits it is definitely
not the same story it's also important
to note the changes to the story that
have been added in one example has to be
the time that these movies take place
it's widely accepted that the FNAF 1
video game takes place somewhere around
1993 and yet in this scene from the
movie we see a date on a security camera
that reads April 6th 2000 about 7 years
later another big example though we've
long theorized that the story of the
original FNAF games takes place in Utah
that is not the case in the film in the
film during the scene where Aunt Jane is
confronting Mike at aby's school her
lawyer hands Mike some family court
paperwork if you pause and read the fine
print on the documents you'll find the
url
mncourts.gov which is the official
website for the Minnesota Judicial
System additionally we can see a phone
number with the area code 651 which is
connected to the St Paul area in eastern
suburbs of Minnesota get this I kid you
not there's a small town in this area
code named Afton you cannot make that up
honestly I wouldn't be surprised if
Scott moved the entire movie to
Minnesota just for that change alone
lastly there's also this decal on
Vanessa's police cruiser gfpd PD stands
for Police Department that part's pretty
darn obvious but then what about the GF
well honestly that could stand for any
City or Township with those same
initials from Grand Forks to Glenn Falls
to Great Falls but included in that list
is Granite Falls just 2 hours west of St
Paul whose cop cars at least according
to the website follow the exact same
black and white color pattern that we
see in the movie speaking of Clues from
the cars that are seen throughout the
movie we can also reasonably assume that
Mike's brother Garrett was kidnapped in
the early 80s based on this shot from
Mike's dream sequence by taking the rear
end of William aton's car here and
reverse image searching for it we're
able to identify this as a Ford Fairmont
Futura specifically the model is coming
from between 1980 and 1983 you can
immediately see the connections here
between the unique vertical tail light
design and the boxy body shape but why
then does that matter well Mike's
brother Garrett is likely the first
child that afon abducted and killed in
Mike's dream flashbacks we very clearly
see Garrett holding a toy airplane as
he's being taken away in the back of
afton's car and where do we see that
airplane again when Vanessa reveals
Afton to be her father she's holding the
same airplane that right there that is
cold gifting toys from your victims to
your daughter but not only is it gross
it's also helpful because it lets us put
together a rough timeline you see Afton
and Vanessa are clearly in a still
operational Pizzeria in this photograph
which means it had to have been taken
before the other kids went missing
causing Freddy's to shut down in other
words Garrett was the first of afton's
victims that we currently know of and
that right there that's important
because in The Games afton's first
victim and the one most closely
associated with his car goes on to
possess the puppet a marionette esque
character that serves as a protector and
guide to all the other Spirit children
it's the first victim that gives gifts
and gives life to the other animatronics
after their murders we see this
possession happening in FNAF 6's
security puppet miname notice the tire
tracks out there in the rain we see the
exact same event from a different angle
in FNAF 2 notice that cool purple car
from there the rest of FNAF 2's hid mini
games then show us the puppet trying to
protect the other dead children from
afon and when it can't the puppet
decides to bring them to life in the
form of
animatronics e g h e m the robotic voice
here is spelling out save them does it
sound familiar it should that same
robotic voice appears at the very end of
the movie's credits g o m e f i m e m e
once the whole thing wraps The Voice has
spelled out come find me in the exact
same way that the puppet communicated to
the player in the FNAF 2 mini games and
who needs to be found in the movie
Garrett see the fact that they never
resolved what exactly happened to
Garrett was a big thing that stuck out
to me when I was watching this thing
after all it was Mike's entire
motivation and his only clear outright
connection to both Afton and Vanessa his
fate is definitely going to come up
again in the sequel and all the signs
are pointing to the puppet from the FNAF
2 video game what's more did you notice
the music that was playing during that
section it's a music box another nod to
the puppet who in the games is kept calm
by constantly winding a music box in
short Garrett Is possessing the puppet
in this world and here he is literally
trying to tell Mike and the audience to
come find him in the sequel but stop for
a minute and consider the method of
aton's crime here it is different from
all the rest he's out in nature he
kidnaps Garett and presumably leaves him
alive longer than his normal victims he
keeps the kid's toy and then gives it to
his daughter they're even in a
completely different state unlike the
rest of afton's crimes where he just
lurs kids to the back of the Pizzeria
and kills them here things feel
premeditated they feel personal and that
would align with both the games and the
books where afton's first murder isn't
just a random killing it's targeted
against one person his business partner
and the original builder of the
animatronics Henry small Souls trapped
in prisons of my making Now set to new
purpose a wound first inflicted on me
but then one that I let bleed out to
cause all of this in fact in the novel
Trilogy Aton does the exact same thing
that he does in the movie he kidnaps
Henry's daughter Charlie before
ultimately killing her basically all
signs point to Garrett not just being a
random victim but rather to him being
the son of afton's partner and rival
Henry the man who helped Afton build all
of the animatronics see as I was piecing
together the details from the movie I
started to notice something The Afton
and Schmidt families from the movie seem
awfully close to the family structures
from the games except in Reverse you see
in the game series we know that Afton
has himself three children Michael
crying child and Elizabeth the oldest
son Michael plays a prank as a kid which
gets his younger brother killed in the
iconic bite of 1983 from there on Mike
becomes obsessed with atoning for his
mistake eventually becoming a security
guard and releasing the spirit of his
brother into the Afterlife then there's
Elizabeth who eventually gets trapped
and dies inside a baby a suit that is
increasingly looking to be a spring lock
animatronic now let's check out the
Schmidt family over in the movie you
have again A family of three two boys
and a girl Mike the older brother is a
security guard who's obsessed with
atoning for the time that got his
younger brother Garrett kidnapped and
killed then there's Abby who's nearly
trapped and killed inside the Ellis suit
a spring lock animatronic they literally
match one for one meanwhile Aton in the
movie seems to have himself only one
daughter Vanessa just like Henry had
himself one daughter Charlie in the
games so if they've switched dynamics
that could make Mike's Dad here the
representative of Henry Emily from the
games her mom died uh a little while
back and Dad he couldn't handle it so
they leave Mike's dad's fate vague to me
looks like it was deliberately done in
case they ever wanted to bring Mike's
dad back into the story in a role
similar to Henry's but perhaps most
interesting of all if you look in the
background of the employee training
video you can see a man who looks very
similar to Mike's Dad working on the
animatronics just like Henry would have
done in the games Cannon this is also as
far as I can tell an uncredited
performance but one look at Mike's dad
this guy from the training video and the
way that Henry's portrayed in places
like the character Encyclopedia it shows
a visual design connection between the
three of them but not only would this
connection fit with the established game
lore it would also explain why William
Aton recognizes Mike early in the movie
we see Afton have a moment of
recognition when he reads Mike's last
name Mr Michael but according to US
Census Data there's around 16 6,000
people with the last name Schmidt here
in the US so either this is just a case
of pure movie coincidence or William
recognizes not only the last name
Schmidt but Mike Schmidt specifically in
the general age range that his partner's
son would be that's why he's so sure
that this is someone from his past more
evidence for this the fact that William
knows that Mike has a brother without it
ever being addressed this is perfect
first I killed your brother now I kill
you sure we can assume the spirit
children told him little ones tell me
you have a sister or maybe Vanessa
that's a bit less satisfying than him
just knowing and taking out his Vendetta
against every member of the Schmidt
family and for those of you saying that
Henry's last name is Emily it might be
but that's never actually been
officially confirmed we've always
thought it was a bit bizarre to have as
a last name and let's be honest it could
just as easily be Charlie's middle name
Charlotte Emily Schmidt but last let's
talk about William you'll notice that I
just pulled the line that indicates that
the spirits talk to William throughout
this movie which is a very important
detail in fact if you notice they really
gave Afton a lot of explicit control
over what the spirits are doing here see
while he seems to understand what was
happening in the games it never seemed
like he could outright control the
animatronics in the books it's a little
bit different he eventually is able to
control the animatronics but not until
the last novel of the trilogy here
though he seems to understand all of it
from the get-go they tell him about Abby
he understands the importance of the
pictures on the wall what have you done
and as the spring locks in his suit are
going off and he's dying what does he do
he basically looks directly in the
camera says his catchphrase I always
come back and puts on the springtrap
helmet why what sense would that make
well it's a pretty clear indication that
this afon explicitly knows how
possession works and it involves being
completely put inside of the suit like
this putting on that helmet is basically
Afton accepting his fate knowing that
he'll be back able to possess the suit
and survive so right here we have
ourselves a smarter afon who is years
further in his understanding of the
spiritual world than either the afon in
the games or the books which leads me to
this an animatronic buried in the parts
and service room of the pizzeria one
that you can't see in the movie but you
can see in the behind the scenes footage
from Doo during his tour of the movie
Set an animatronic with rounded human
skull silver eyes and human teeth well
this could just be background set
dressing I don't think that's the case
if this is truly an afon who understands
the power of Agony in granting eternal
life if this is an Afton who has gone so
far as to build a Freddy torture chair
for extracting Remnant from his victims
I'm thinking his experiments with
building passible robotic humans has
already begun this isn't just me playing
the robot Gregory game again it is the
only explanation for the parts and
surfaces room to an animatronic with
human teeth and realistic human head
proportions and eyes and above it
hanging from the top of the shop a
robotic hand with five fully
articulating fingers and human
proportions no other animatronic in this
series fits this sort of description
does this mean he's already built a
humanoid or is this just an early phase
of his experiments it's unclear but it
does give a bit more credit to Vanessa's
bloodless Stab Wound at the end of the
movie being more than just an excuse to
get itself a PG-13 rating my real guess
though is that there's a robot Garrett
walking around and that he'll be the
reveal at the end of the movie just like
Charlie the puppet is revealed to be a
robot at the end of the fourth closet a
world shattering Revelation for Mike as
he comes to terms with the nature of his
brother and his father's weird Creations
before the final movie where he's tasked
with having to burn it all down honestly
the pieces are in place for us or not
all the next movie has to do is drop a
Markiplier Cameo and then show me a clip
of mangle and I'm in but hey one last
reminder to check out our incredible
officially licensed FNAF merch grab them
while they are remaining remaining
remaning the last thing you want is the
agony of knowing that they've sold out
when you wanted one and as always my
friends remember it's all just a theory
a film Theory and
cut